[Music]
on this monday night the firestorm over
wildfires
flames ripping across the u.s west coast
sending choking smoke
north of the border it's something we
really do not want coinciding with
a viral lung infection as fury ignites
over president trump's inaction
on climate change if you give a climate
arsonist four more years in the white
house
why would anyone be surprised if we have
more america blaze
physically distant decision day in new
brunswick we're definitely the canary in
the coal mine
the challenge of casting ballots in a
pandemic
plus signs of life in the clouds of
venus
what scientists discovered and what it
means
and hold still candid moments
captured of life in lockdown
global national with donna friesen
it is a firestorm of epic proportions
and it is still getting worse across
america's west coast
what hasn't already been incinerated is
under threat from fires moving so fast
some people are running for their lives
i personally had an interaction with a
couple that had barely had time to get
out of bed and get out of their front
door
and jump in the river where they spent
many hours
escaping the flames not everyone has
been able to escape more than 30 people
are dead dozens of others are missing
thousands of homes have been reduced to
embers entire towns burned to the ground
and even where there are no fires there
is choking smoke
good evening and thanks for joining us
air quality is terrible in some cities
not just close to the fires but
far away new satellite images show it
blowing from
the west coast of north america all the
way over to the great lakes
forecast models show the smoke will keep
spreading east
in the coming days and this is vancouver
today thick smoke made the middle of the
day look dark and hazy
visibility at the airport was just over
a kilometer
conditions were so bad today canada post
suspended delivery saying the air is too
unsafe for workers
and at one point today vancouver was
again ranked as the worst city in the
world
for air quality according to the air
quality health index which measures the
health
impacts on a scale of one to ten metro
vancouver was
off the charts today air pollution from
the fires
is raising red flags along the west
coast from vancouver
all the way down to mexico all of this
is happening in the midst of a pandemic
and as kids go back to school when
access to fresh air is supposed to help
keep people safe
for weeks now daily numbers of covid 19
have been on the rise in parts of
western canada
heather yorick's west reports on how the
smoke could make the kovid 19 situation
even worse susan denev has been heading
outdoors as
much as possible over the past few
months to reduce the risk of covet 19
transmission but breathing in smoky air
wasn't part of the deal i can feel it in
my throat but that's about it
i can smell the smoke for sure and stuff
there's a bit of a breeze so that
keeps everything flowing smoke from
fires in the u.s drifted into alberta
saskatchewan and manitoba monday
though the risk to air quality across
the prairies remained
low but in much of southern bc the smoke
is so
thick that anyone with health conditions
is advised to limit their activities
outdoors
across the border the city of seattle
closed its covet 19 testing sites
because of the poor air quality the
problem is inhaling wildfire smoke can
cause
inflammation in your lungs and that
inflammation can make you more
prone to infections like the ones caused
by covid19
so not only are there people perhaps
with underlying conditions that this
could make it worse and then if they get
coveted things
things may get bad but also people that
may otherwise be a mild case might have
more severe disease
which could lead to more people with
covid19 being hospitalized
it could also mean more infections as
people seek shelter
inside people tend to then move indoors
to try and get out of the smoke so we
are going to be driving
people into those indoor environments
where once again the virus is able to
spread
the bc teachers federation took its
concern to twitter sunday
teachers and students should not be in
crowded classes with no
ventilation or fresh air yes it is
perfectly safe
for people to be in the school but we
don't want the windows open we want to
reduce the amount of smoke that's coming
in
but we have other things in place for
covet as well
so we need to make sure that we're
adhering to those precautions
the wildfire is adding another layer of
worry
onto a situation with so much
uncertainty
on its own heather urex west global news
calgary
california's governor who met with
president trump today made it clear
what's stoking the fires
climate change something gavin newsom
said has changed the plumbing of the
world
the hots are getting hotter the dries
are getting drier
when we're having heat domes the likes
of which we've never seen in our history
the hottest august ever the history of
the state climate change is real
and that is exacerbating this president
trump is in stark disagreement with
newsome and other western governors over
the cause of these fires he blames
state mismanagement of the forests as
eric sorenson reports nobody wants to
see
all this destruction but it could force
climate change
onto the agenda in november's
presidential election
it's the largest wildfire in the history
of california
flames have ravaged forests in
washington state and fire has
incinerated communities in oregon
it's like the seven plagues biblical
sense
it has taken all of that to prompt a
visit to the west coast by u.s president
donald trump
we have meetings with fema and we have
meetings with a lot of people having to
do with california washington state
and oregon and i think they'll go very
well they're doing an incredible job but
the political gulf between trump's
washington and west coast
states could not be wider washington
oregon and california have not voted for
a republican for president
since ronald reagan more than 30 years
ago and trump's stance on the defining
issue of climate change
is flatly contradicted by three
democratic governors
they deserve action against climate
change we have not seen this level of
uncontained fire ever in oregon history
this is a climate dam emergency this is
real
but president trump has dismissed
climate change rolled back environmental
laws and blamed wildfires on state
mismanagement of the forests
you know it is about forest management
please remember the words very simple
forest management trump is focused on
his re-election
unlikely to win over the west coast and
as a result unlikely to change his views
he doesn't believe uh much in the
science and he clearly doesn't
understand anything about climate change
policy or law that it's not that
important
particularly because california is a
blue state and it's very clear that
trump is only interested in governing
his supporters the wildfires have turned
a slow-motion disaster
climate change into an urgent issue
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden
seized the moment to declare trump out
of step with the needs of a country
facing multiple crises if you give a
climate arsonist
four more years in the white house why
would anyone be surprised if we have
more
america blaze biden says he would follow
the science to address
climate change the science predicts more
wildfires with greater intensity over a
longer season in the years ahead
trump seems convinced his supporters
will not abandon him over climate policy
perhaps calculating that on the west
coast there aren't enough of them to
make a difference in november's election
anyway eric sorensen global news toronto
president trump has issued emergency
declarations for the states of louisiana
and mississippi as hurricane
sally approaches it's one in a series of
major storms brewing along the u.s gulf
coast
the national hurricane center has issued
advisories about five
tropical cyclones over the atlantic
basin tying a record last set in 1971
two of them are now category two
hurricanes paulette is already battering
bermuda
sally is closing in on the florida
panhandle renee
teddy and vicki are also spinning over
ocean waters now to the concerning rise
in cases of covet 19 in parts of canada
ontario recorded its biggest daily
increase since early june most of the
cases are linked
to private social gatherings 313 new
cases were reported in ontario today
that's more than a 50 percent increase
from the day before
there are cause for concern for all of
us
let me be crystal clear every option is
on the table
we will take every step necessary
including further shutdowns
daily cases are up again in quebec 276
were reported today
alberta saw a jump of 140 b.c
reported 61 new cases today new
brunswick
had just one new case today and voters
there have successfully completed a
first
it is the first province or territory to
hold an election
during the pandemic and conservative
premier blaine higgs who won a minority
in 2018
is on course to a majority tonight the
polls closed not long ago and global
news is projecting a conservative
majority
liberal leader kevin vickers who has
never held public office was hoping for
a breakthrough tonight but it's not
clear
whether he'll even win his seat here's
what the early results are showing the
popular vote percentage is close but
the progressive conservatives are
leading or elected in 27 seats
the liberals in 17 the green party
leading are elected in three in the
people's alliance
in two seats the conservatives need 25
seats
to form a majority our ross lord is in
fredericton tonight ross
blaine higgs took a risk calling this
election and it paid off for him
oh yeah donna this outcome means more
authority for higgs
pcs and less influence in fact
really no influence for the liberals the
green party
and the people's alliance and it seems
it was an outcome new brunswickers were
very eager to deliver
these voters in fredericton lined up
before their polling station opened
eager to play their part in a peculiar
election
i think it's being handled very well and
we have to do our duty you know yellow
line six feet apart everybody's wearing
masks
fewer voters than usual are allowed
inside as election planners try to limit
crowds
and keep a lid on the novel coronavirus
poll workers
are instructed to sanitize ballot
markers after each use
new measures for a new kind of election
we're definitely the canary in the coal
mine on this whole
election during a pandemic so we
definitely will have some lessons
learned
the campaign included far less door
knocking than usual
some liberal candidates went door to
door progressive conservative leader
blaine higgs told his candidates to stay
away
so i could get all the information i
needed about the candidates on facebook
here more than most districts every vote
counts fredericton north
is a key battleground riding the
liberals took it two years ago but just
barely
if it swings to the pcs it could
indicate a larger shift
higgs is riding a wave of popularity
from his management of the covet 19
crisis political analysts say going to
the polls
was higgs attempt to strengthen his
vulnerable minority government
he saw an opportunity to score a
majority government against a weak
inexperienced leader of the liberal
party liberal leader kevin vickers is
best known
as the sergeant-at-arms who helped stop
a gunman on parliament hill
in 2014. in a campaign unlike any other
this is vickers first attempt at running
for public office
that is ross lord reporting from new
brunswick where global news is
projecting a conservative majority
government
prime minister justin trudeau and his
cabinet are getting their ducks in a row
before the next session of parliament
they held a cabinet retreat in ottawa
today and the pandemic not surprisingly
dominated the agenda abigail beeman is
there
meeting in the same room for the first
time in six months
cabinet is also on the same page about
priorities
the most important thing right now is to
fight the pandemic
we still have to ensure that canadians
are safe
that we that we make the best decisions
based on
on the best health advice the
government's first priority has been and
will continue to be supporting people
through this
like the rest of us they're watching
case numbers climb
the last thing anyone wants is to go
into this fall
and lock down similar to this spring and
the way we can prevent that
is by remaining vigilant and figuring
out how to do that tops the agenda the
prime minister
says conversations around next steps
support for child care housing
long-term care are happening too but our
focus is very much
on what we need to do to control covet
19.
cabinet heard from key players on the
culvert 19 file and
key foreign affairs figures the
ambassadors to the united nations the
united states and china
ministers are working on the throne
speech too coming next week
global news learn plans to spend up to a
hundred billion dollars in green
spending
were shelved but the environment
minister stressed climate change is
still critical
i don't think the government is backing
off on anything the liberals also aren't
backing off a fight with the u.s
over aluminum tariffs tuesday morning
deputy prime minister christopher
freeland is expected to announce
details on counter tariff measures the
government has said they'll match the
u.s
dollar for dollar that means 3.6 billion
abigail beeman and global news ottawa
off the rails coming up the cleanup in
bc after a train plunges into a creek
plus who cut the cable on a popular
tourist attraction for a second time
and a devastating fire destroys an
historic pier
this four-alarm fire ripped through an
historic pier near vancouver last night
firefighters say the blaze at the pier
park in new westminster could linger for
days
the pier decking has to be lifted so
firefighters can access what's burning
underneath
toxic smoke from the pilings of the pier
is hampering their efforts
and nearby schools and businesses have
closed because of the poor air quality
the cause of the fire is under
investigation
also in bc a cn train derailed causing
about 60 cars to pile up
in a creek bed it happened early this
morning on a bridge near hope about two
hours east of vancouver
a number of cars carrying potash ended
up in the water
an environmental assessment team is now
at the scene
no one was hurt and the cause of the
derailment is under investigation
for the second time in just over a year
vandalism has shut down a popular bc
tourist attraction
early this morning while the facility
was closed a cable was cut on the ceta
sky gondola in squamish
30 cars went crashing to the ground the
rcmp are investigating
the cable was cut for the first time in
august of last year that cost
millions of dollars to repair and the
facility had only reopened
in february you know i've been in the
lift business my whole entire life and
and these are unique and incredibly rare
events so to happen to happen twice
speaks more to the motivation of the
person who wants to bring
this team this company in this community
to its knees and that's not going to
happen
the investigation into last year's
incident is still ongoing
security has been beefed up since then
and this time the company says police
were alerted after an automatic motion
detection system went off
about 4 am still ahead the small signs
of life that are a big deal
on a planet that is blistering hot
there's a bold claim being made about a
tiny find it may be the closest we've
come to proving we're not alone in the
universe
astronomers have discovered a potential
sign of life in the clouds over
venus earth's closest neighbor
scientists are trying to figure out
where it came from and what it means
and as mike armstrong reports it's
generating a lot of excitement
it was a discovery made almost by
accident
scientists using this radio telescope in
chile and another in hawaii
were looking for something basically to
prove it wasn't there
they scanned venus for phosphine gas to
show the planet's limits
well it turned out not to have the
limits scientists thought it had
i was just stunned i'm i mean i did this
as an interesting experiment
i'd never really thought about detecting
it
what they found isn't life it's a bio
signature
it's something usually produced by
something living on earth phosphine gas
is produced by bacteria
in environments with very little oxygen
with venus the scientists
tried to find another explanation for
the phosphine but had to rule all of
them out
not a single process we looked at could
produce phosphine in
in high enough quantities to explain our
team's findings of phosphine in the
venous atmosphere
now we've sent probes and landers to
venus before the first one was 60 years
ago this past spring
it's our closest neighbor one planet
over just 143 million kilometers away
while the surface of venus is too hot
for anything to live there it's hot
enough to melt lead
but it's believed that billions of years
ago the surface was
cooler and wetter and may have had life
as it warmed up some of that life might
have evolved
up into the high clouds 50 or 60
kilometers in the skies over venus
conditions are still very rough windy
and acidic but the pressure is similar
to earth's
and the temperature is about 30 degrees
celsius those are conditions that
could sustain life now what would that
life look like
canadian astronomer netari wallet says
they'd be microbes
unlike anything we're used to anything
that would be
life like as we know it on earth would
need to have like a protective shell
of graphite or something that's
protecting it from the
acid wallet describes herself as
cautiously
very excited finding even some strange
microbond venus
would mean life on another planet and
that further out in the galaxy
there's likely even more mike armstrong
global news
montreal hold still
next a new exhibit captures history in
the making
never in modern times has the world
endured what we're living through right
now
a pandemic that has touched every
country that has killed more than 900
000 people the scale is so massive it's
best captured
in small moments a new photo exhibit in
london curated by the duchess of
cambridge and the national portrait
gallery
showcases the perseverance the helpers
the
acts of kindness over 31 000 images were
sent in by people across the uk
their feelings put into context by queen
elizabeth in her address to the nation
this spring i hope in the years to come
everyone will be able to take pride in
how they responded to this challenge
and those who come after us will say the
britons of this generation were as
strong as any
our europe bureau chief crystal gomezing
has the story behind
some of the pictures
the images tell the collective
experience of lockdown
one family one neighborhood one
isolating flash at a time
she was totally just in her own
world do you know what i mean like she
would that was definitely not a posed or
staged photo
and i took it and i just kind of looked
at the digital screen and i was like oh
my god this is so nice i really love it
so did a panel of judges including the
duchess of
cambridge lottie sofia's photo of her
flatmate
pepter was selected from thousands and
is now featured on the national portrait
gallery's website
the holdsdale project was months in the
making
together i hope that we can build a
lasting illustration
of just how our country pulled together
during the pandemic so to let you go
from normality to
no school no nanny no aunties no cousins
no going
out it was you know it was it was a
shock for them
on international nurses day amelia's mom
made her a little paper costume
she posted it to social media and her
followers right away
said she had to enter it in the photo
contest
it's amazing um it's very surreal for
the down syndrome community to have
amelia
represent them in such a historic event
as just
fantastic amelia is an ambassador for
wouldn't change a thing
her nickname is cheeky chops but she was
a little shy during our chat
you really like your picture yeah yeah
certainly you know we will all be
looking back
on this experience in 2020 and decades
to come in generations to come
it was a bit bleak really but at least
some really good
things have come out of it for quite a
lot of people it seems
100 snapshots of history from people of
different ages
telling one story crystal commansing
global news
london and that is global national for
this monday i'm donna friesen we leave
you tonight with some portraits of
groundbreaking canadians
canada post has released a series of new
stamps to honor six physicians and
medical researchers
their work led to advancements in
science and medicine around the world
the series has been in development for
years and happens to launch as research
into a new vaccine
is in the spotlight thanks for watching
take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you